la chronique culture pour poursuivre
cette édition du 78 Joan de nouveaux
invités sur le plateau oui trois
nouveaux invités alors nous vons
commencer par les dames honneur aux
dames donc Catherine Schwarz vous êtes
artiste et vous présentez vos œuvres
dans l'exposition screenplay qui se
déroule en ce moment à Guy encour une
exposition organisée mise en place par
Yanne Lapoire qui est à côté de moi
bonsoir et on va partir avant d'aller à
Guy encour on va faire une petite
escapade une petite une grande cap même
au Sénégal avec dijibril gouiabi vous
êtes comédien et metteur en scène dans
la compagnie bousana vous allez jouer ce
vendredi le 23 novembre à 20h30 au
Théâtre Robert Manuel à plaisir alors
cette cette intervention s'inscrit dans
le cadre de la Semaine de la solidarité
internationale soutenue par des
associations locales comme Amnesy
internationale vous êtes un habitué de
cette semaine vous venez régulièrement
chaque année à à plaisir c'est la 4è
fois je crois fr voilà exactement c'est
la 4e fois que nous venons à plaisir
pour présenter nos créations on était
venu euh il y a de cela je CIS 3 4 ans
pour vous présenter Allah n'est pas
obligé qui est un roman que nous avons
adapté du roman de
amadououroman donc qui parle de la
problématique des enfants soldats
ensuite on est revenu pour présenter à
l'année comment dirais-je le destin d'un
cl destin là c'est un One mon show c'est
c'est vraiment du voà que je joue que je
je continue de jouer toujours et ensuite
là on est revenu pour présenter des m
Kitu voilà c'est sur le cousinage à
plaisanterie effectivement voilà dernier
spectacle dernière création c'est écrit
cette pièce voilà ce qui est intéressant
dans ce cette cette pièce c'est que
c'est d'abord écrit par un Sénégalais
ensuite par donc c'est coécrit en
quelque sorte donc un Sénégalais et un
français donc du coup c'est c'est
vraiment intéressant du point de vue de
l'échange du point de vue du partage du
point de vue de la culture et donc dans
cette pièce qui est drôle vous dénoncez
quand même certains mots de la société
voilà donc le comédien c'est en quelque
sorte comme le dit quelqu'un c'est il
interroge la société il pose des
questions il est à l'écoute de sa
société donc pour nous c'est important
de parler d'un spectacle de qui parle un
peu disons de nos réalités donc nos
réalités veut dire les réalités de
l'autre parce que aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un village planétaire il y a
pas de frontière sur sur l'Internet
voilà alors concrètement dans dans cette
pièce des mot Kitu vous abordz des
thèmes comme les communautés entre
notamment les chrétiens euh les
musulmans voilà donc ça part déjà de ça
s'appelle le cousinage à plaisanterie le
cousinage à plaisanterie c'est quoi on
dit que c'est un pacte que nous avons
irriqué de nos ancêtres et ce pacte
disons sert un peu disons à préserver le
bon voisinage donc du coup ça part de
cette légende qui parle de ce cousinage
à plaisanterie donc du coup qui parle de
de de de ces ethnies de ces communautés
pour dire en quelque sorte que voilà il
y a pas de différence entre un peul d'un
Manding un peul ou bien un noir d'un
français on peut le généraliser comme ça
et ensuite ite un peu plus loin on parle
ça nous permet d'aborder la question des
religions que nous traversons
actuellement même si peut-être au
Sénégal il y a pas forcément cette
question euh cette problématique mais un
peu à côté au Mali aujourd'hui nous voit
on voyons bien ce qui se passe là-bas
quoi et dans ce mondelà et et ensuite on
part un peu plus loin dans ce mondelà
nous vivons la problématique un peu
disons aussi de la
question de de voyage quand tu voilà il
y a certains noms quand tu dis
euh ben du coup tout de suite ça peut
faire le nom de la compagnie d'ailleurs
bousana c'est fait aussi écho un peu au
voyage voilà c'est c'est un peu nous
avons pensé néaire de garder un pe
disons cette symbolique de comment
dirais-je d'abord bousana bousana veut
dire là le fromager ou c'est pas l'arbre
qui donne du fromage non non du tout
c'est c'est c'est c'est un grand arbre
géant où les gens se retrouvent pour
prendre des décisions importantes sur la
vie mais ensuite c'est avec le Trô de
cet arbre que nous qu'on construit la
Piro et la Pyo ça sert à voyager aller à
la rencontre de l'autre euh pour
partager échanger découvrir c'est pour
nous c'est ça qui cette symbolique là
vous parlez de la thématique de la
religion que vous abordez tout à l'heure
c'est difficile à aborder en ce moment
on regarde tout ce qui peut se passer en
France par exemple toutes les
discussions oui pasme facile he oui oui
effectivement mais pour nous ce qui est
intéressant dans ce spectacle c'est que
nous nous prenons la laïcité on parle on
aborde la comment dirait cette question
de la religion en essayant de
représenter trois personnages le
chrétien le musulman mais l'animiste au
Sénégal nous avons euh l'animisme qui
est qui qui occupe presque 5 % le mus la
religion musulmane qui occupe 95 % et
l'animisme qui occupe 100 % voilà donc
cela veut dire quoi cela veut dire que
on voit bien ces religions révélées qui
sont présentes mais par contre il y a la
religion animiste qui est toujours là
quoi et qui occupe vraiment bien du
terrain et euh ce qui est intéressant au
Sénégal même si il y a la rion musulmane
qui qui qui occupe une grande place mais
du coup on on voit bien que il y a cet
échange les gens partagent un peison
autour même même dans la même famille on
peut retrouver des personnes de la de
religion crrétienne de religion
musulmane et de religions animiste donc
c'est très sympathique voilà quand c'est
la fête de du musulman c'est le c'est la
fête tous les jours pour tout le monde
c'est la f tous les jours vous voyagez
beaucoup alors quand vous voyagez en
France au Sénégal ou ailleurs aussi dans
d'autres pays d'Europe vous me disiez
tout à l'heure vous voyez des
différences de réaction en fonction des
public oui effectivement donc c'est
c'est ça permet de de de de revenir sur
la question de l'écriture donc c'est
écrit par un Sénégalais mais aussi par
un Français et du coup
euh on voit bien la réaction au Sénégal
c'est pas pareil qu'en France euh
certains endroits où par exemple euh
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est le
Sénégalais qui qui qui qui a écrit
forcément on voit bien pour disons cette
réaction les gens réagissent plus par
contre si on arrive en France c'est
différent la réaction n'est pas la même
et du côté de de de des endroits où
c'est écrit par le français on voit bien
aussi la réaction qui est différente de
celle de du Sénégal donc je pense que
c'est c'est vraiment intéressant au
niveau de ce spectacle là et et du coup
les gens à la sortie du spectacle on dit
mais c'est vraiment intéressant du point
de vue déjà de l'échange euh du point de
vue du partage du point de vue de voilà
et et scéniquement ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que on voit bien
euh euh et ça c'est voulu quelque part
de faire de sorte que euh euh c'est pas
seulement la parole on voit bien que
c'est un spectacle où c'est la parole
qui occupe une bonne place mais du coup
elle est complétée par le corp bien sûr
donc le corps a un rôle bien comment
dira très intéressant dans ce spectacle
là c'est c'est presque même les pas sont
millimétrés en quelque sorte il une
chorégraphie pres c'est une chorégraphie
tout le spectacle est chorégraphi en
quelque sorte voilà euh donc la la
compagnie existe depuis
19993 voilà nous sommes les membres
fondateurs de cette compagnie voilà et
vous menez différentes action vous jouez
comme ça à l'étranger vous donnez des
cours aussi vous formez des comédiens
oui je je je pense que c'est important
nous sommes dans un une société où des
des fois prendre la parole pour un jeune
de rien du tout c'est pas évident quand
tu prends la parole ont dire non non non
non tu tu tu es petit non non non att
c'est les c'est c'est les grands qui
décident et tout ça donc pour nous c'est
c'est intéressant de de donner la parole
à tout le monde c'estàd quand on est sur
la scène et surtout en utilisant
l'humour ça passe mieux les gens il se
disent ah non non non on les laisse pas
et du coup on fait on on fait passer on
pose des questions on fait pas passer
des messages mais on pose des questions
on interroge notre société donc c'est au
public de de de de trouver la la réponse
que nous essayons depposer quoi et ça
c'est important ce que vous dites il y a
pas de de message que vous imposez vous
soulevez des problématiques effectiv
vraiment le but c'est des interrogations
effectivement on n' pas la prétention
d'apporter des des questions des
réponses ou bien de excusez-moi ou bien
de de de de de trouver de solutions non
loin de là c'est loin de là des voilà
c'est et du coup comme je le disais
tantôt les gens ils sont vraiment à la
sortie du spectacle ils sont ravis et
ils sont vraiment contents de de
partager un spectacle certes africain
mais voilà aujourd'hui qui traitent des
problèmes pas traite mais qui qui pose
des des des des des questions à des
sociétés sénégalaises à la société de
notre monde de notre village planétaire
et vous passez aussi au Festival
d'Avignon voilà donc on a participé euh
d'abord en 2009 avec spectacle en en
2005 en 2009 et ce spectacle là va être
présenté au Festival d'Avignon en cette
année en
2000 2013 2013 201 presque fini 2012 SAF
si c'est la fin du monde le 21 décembre
rapère pas on rappelle les dates
peut-être du spectacle donc PLA c'est
vendredi le 23 ce vendredi 23 novembre à
20h30 au théâtre Robert Manuel à plaisir
et vous avez le numéro de téléphone qui
s'affiche si vous voulez avoir des infos
et les résa et si vous avez le temps il
y a un petit un petit truc qu'on peut
peut-être faire passer après si vous
avez du temps allez-y voilà allez-y suff
demander voilà voilà donc c'était juste
un petit on est là on est je crois pour
parler un peu disons de la parole voilà
et il était une fois de fois TR fois 4
fois 5 fois 6 fois 7 fois un couple un
couple qui avait un enfant cet enfantl
avait 2 ans 3 ans 4 ans 5 ans 6 ans 7
ans il ne parlait pas 8 ans 9 ans 10 ans
12 ans 13 ans il ne parlait pas et un
jour pendant qu'on était sur l'ARB
palabre pour la première fois l'enfant
commençait à faire comme ça et sa maman
qui commence à dire chérie tu as vu
notre enfant va parler et pour la
première fois l'enfant va dire
grand-père et mais c'était la joie dans
la famille quoi et le lendemain matin
grand-père est mort c'est triste mais il
y a pas de problème on enterre et le sur
lendemain toujours toutable je vous l'ai
dire sous l'arbarab c'est vraiment
comment dir l'Assemblée nationale c'est
là où on se réunit pour prendre des
décisions important sur la vie et pour
la deuxième fois l'enfant va faire comme
ça son papa qui dit chéri ta vie notre
enfant va parler et tout de suite il dit
tonton et le lendemain matin ton est
mort non mais c'est triste hein mais
vous allez voir c'est pas triste et du
coup on enterre et le sur rend toujours
sur je voulaai dit en train de prendre
du thé et le thé chez nous c'est pas
comme chez vous chez nous c'est tout un
il faut soulever le verre mais non mais
non et pour la troisème fois l'enfant va
ouvrir la bouche il va faire comme ça
il dit
papa chérie tu as vu h c'est pas bon si
je vais mourir
chérie je vais mourir et le lendemain
matin qu'est-ce qu'on voit c'est Abdou
le cordier du village qui est mort et je
vous le dis hein pour la première fois
j'ai vu un homme remercier sa femme pour
l'avoir trahi chérie merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci à Gibril gouab pour
cette interprétation cette petite
parenthèse en plateau merci à vous
hésitez pas on va faire on va faire
revenir régulièrement sur le plateau
pour ponctuer l'émission on fait une
pause Joann on se retrouve en plateau
juste après mais on on part pour une
exposition oui ben oui on a parler de
voyage tout ça ça me fait penser un peu
aux cartes postales et justement en ce
moment il y a une exposition à la à
l'Orangerie du domaine de Madame
ellisabeth à Versailles autour des
cartes postal mais du début du 20e
siècle on regarde ça tout de
suite une carte postale grandeur nature
en guise de bienvenue à l'Orangerie du
domaine de Madame ellisabeth plus de 200
cartes postales datant de 1890 à 1920
raconte l'histoire de notre département
les
Yvelines le département des Yvelines au
début du 20e siècle n'existait pas on n
connaissait même pas le nom puisque nous
parlions simplement de la sénéoise et le
département des Yvelines a vu sa
naissance et son contour en
1968 à l'initiative du Conseil Général
l'exposition recto verso a pu voir le
jour grâce à diverses associations
yvelinoise dont celle des cartes
postales du 78 à laquelle appartient
Olivier de l commissaire de l'exposition
ce support média au début du 20e siècle
c'était le seul témoignage qui existait
pour communiquer nous n'avions pas de
télévision nous n'avions pas d'internet
nous n'avions aucun média elle
présentaiit qu'elles étaient les dans
les villages dans les campagnes dans les
villes toutes les actions qui étaient
faites il y avait une fête il y avait
des cartes postales il y avait un
accident il y avait des cartes postales
il y avait des mariages il y avait des
cartes postales chacun se montrait dans
son magasin dans sa boutique dans sa vie
au quotidien ien les cartes postales du
début du 20e siècle deviennent de
véritables témoins du passé ell
proposent un regard ludique sur notre
histoire à la sortie de RCK en cour et
qu'on va vers versaill la carte passale
où vous voyez vous avez ça a pas
beaucoup changé sauf que vous avez une
seule voiture imaginez-vous aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes là c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure en venant les
commissaires Olivier Delas et Catherine
Lecomte ont organisé l'exposition autour
de thématiqu comme la belle époque la
ville et le village l'enseignement ou
encore l'industrie on a toutes les des
cartes postales rien que sur les Ines il
y en a des millions et des millions
voilà on a 39 cantons donc on veut au
moins une cartte par canton et le target
maximum était de 150 cartes mais bon on
a puisé au travers de ce qu'on appelle
les plus belles cartes des Yvelines et
on a un petit peu dérivé puisqu'on est à
un peu plus de 270 cartes postales
l'exposition ravira les cartophiles les
curieux ou les historiens jusqu'en
février 2013 pour les plus intéressés
des visit guidé sont prévu les 2 et 9
décembre ainsi que les 13 et 27 janvier
à 15h autre événement à ne pas rater
pour les amateurs de timbre et de cte
postal les 80 ans de l'amical
philatélique et carte auhil de
Versailles les 8 et 9
décembre